un caban discussions communes 36
monsieur lévy
oui merci monsieur le président michel
ministre madame et messieurs les
rapporteurs monsieur le président la
commission des lois mes chers collègues
cet amendement a pour objet d'apporter
plus de clarté de visibilité et me
semble le type de bon sens en ce qui
concerne les georges dans les stades et
les stades le spectacle
en effet depuis le 3 janvier dernier il
ya des gens rejet maximal qui ont été
mises en place par le gouvernement donc
de 5000 spectateurs pour les stades et
de 2000 pour les soldes spectacle en
d'autres termes cela veut dire qu'au
parc des princes il est possible
d'accueillir cinq mille spectateurs pour
une capacité de 50 mille places et à
paris la défense a rien à settat du
racing 92 2000 spectateurs pour 30000
places car elle est considérée comme une
salle de spectacle dans le même temps le
stade de 5000 places pourra faire le
plein tout comme une salle de spectacles
de 2000 personnes où est la cohérence
dans cette décision un amendement que je
propose est soutenu par de très nombreux
sénateurs vient inscrire dans le marbre
une règle claire permettant aux clubs
professionnels et aux organisateurs de
spectacles d'avoir de la visibilité en
effet des questions de tenir compte de
la capacité d'accueil en mettant en
place une charge supplémentaire de 50%
au-delà de la franchise annoncées par le
gouvernement c'est à dire 2000 pour les
stades pour les salles de spectacles et
sa mine pour les stades vous conviendrez
qu'accueillir 27000 personnes au parc
des princes où 40 2000 au stade de
france par ailleurs tous vaccinés et
masqués puisque soumise aux passes
vaccinale ne paraît pas déraisonnable le
spectacle vivant et le monde sportif
professionnel rencontre depuis près de
deux ans des difficultés financières
très importantes et des mécanismes de
compensation mise en place n'ont pas
suffi à les endiguer maintenir des
capacités d'accueil aussi faible
conduirait certainement pas très court
terme a achevé certaines de ces
structures c'est la raison pour laquelle
je pense qu'il est très important
d'adapter ce dispositif existant et je
vous demande les chers collègues de
voter cet amendement ainsi chers
collègues 119g benarroch
dans le même sens que l'as monaco vient
défendre monsieur lévy effectivement il
nous apparaît plus opportun de permettre
la mise en oeuvre de mesures
d'encadrement des conditions d'accès de
présence dans certains lieux et dans
certain catégorie d'établissements
recevoir du public en fonction des
capacités d'accueil des 10
établissements et non pas en valeur
absolue qui n'auraient pas fait au cas
aucun critère objectif d évitement de la
propagation du virus cette mesure avait
d'ailleurs été adopté par la majorité
présidentielle en commission à
l'assemblée nationale elle permet
d'objectiver de proportionnelle et
georges avant que le gouvernement ne
choisisse de d'associer à cette rechute
capacité d'accueil
la situation sanitaire et l'ensemble des
caractéristiques non objectivables de
ces établissements je sais que le
rapporteur a essayé de trouver une
écriture de copeaux me procurer cette
décision mais en fait au vu réellement
de l'objectif d'éviter une propagation
je pense que le la définition de george
lee aux capacités d'accueil de chaque
salle et de chaque stade qui sont bien
connus et qui sont des éléments qui sont
facilement vérifiables et connue de
toutes les autorités y compris des
autorités sportives et culturelles et du
préfet permettrait effectivement
d'obtenir l'objectif qui a cherché avec
le principe de georges
merci 74
oui merci monsieur le président il va
écouter mes chers collègues cet
amendement va tout à fait dans le même
sens puisqu'il propose encadrer l'accès
aux erp et en prévoyant que les jauges
seront déterminés en tenant compte de la
configuration et de la capacité
d'accueil des établissements concernés
mais de manière proportionnelle et je
crois que c'est là où notre amendement
est un peu différent de celui du
rapporteur c'est la proportionnalité je
pense qu'en plus cet amendement permet
de prendre en compte la question des
réalités territoriales et laisse
effectivement le pouvoir réglementaire à
l'autorité préfectorale en concertation
avec les élus de finir des seuils
adaptée en fonction de la capacité
d'accueil des établissements concernés
c'est à la fois une mesure de bon sens
mais derrière et je voudrais terminer
par là puisqu'ils valant un même
philosophie que ceux de mes collègues il
y à une question économique parce que la
question des lieux à la fois sportif et
culturel et bien sont fondées aussi sur
des questions économiques et je crois
qu'il ne faut pas surtout dans le
contexte actuel est bien balayer cette
cette dimension aussi rapidement donc
voilà un peu l'objet de notre amendement
mais c'est le président était de 59
monsieur folio
merci monsieur le président un mes chers
collègues
le monde du sport comme le monde de la
culture ont été particulièrement impacté
par cette crise et cela dans un cadre un
petit peu globale et générale tant au
niveau du sport amateur que du sport
professionnel
cet amendement vise par rapport à la
jauge et on a bien entendu les débats
qui ont été ceux au sein de l'assemblée
nationale est la position du
gouvernement visant à à dire que tous
les systèmes de jean proportionnelle
serait peut-être compliqué à mettre en
place ce qui reste à discuter et en ce
sens cet amendement vient en complément
des amendements donc qui viennent d'être
défendus à l'instant il vise à apporter
pour tous les événements qui sont à
l'extérieur donc dans les stades ou
d'événements culturels une jauge à 10000
e personne parce que actuellement nous
sommes à 5000 ce chiffre est un chiffre
j'irai très subjectif à bien des égards
et par rapport à cela il est nécessaire
de rappeler que pour des personnes qui
sont masquées donc en étant en extérieur
la probabilité de contes animés de
contamination est somme toute assez
faible au delà de ces éléments cet
amendement vise à poser un enjeu et qui
est un jeu spécifique par rapport au
monde du rugby puisque l'économie du
rugby professionnel repose sur les
spectateurs et non pas comme celui du
football qui repose sur les droits
télévisés et donc dans ce cadre là il
est important de rappeler que par
rapport aux précédentes georges l'état
s'était engagé à des éléments de
compensation et qu'à ce jour il reste
toujours 25 millions qui n'ont pas été
versés donc au rugby professionnel ce
qui pose un certain nombre de problèmes
d' équilibre pour pour les clubs donc au
travers de cet amendement c'est
l'objectif de fixer un certain nombre de
règles qui permetteront d'impacter le
moins possible les clubs de rugby
professionnel ces chers collègues le
106,9 et laroche
on n'a rien à voir avec les quatre
précédents même s'il est étudiée en même
temps puisqu'il parle pas des jauges
enfin bon il a été il a été inclus dans
la même dans la même série en fait
je vous le rappelle nous l'avions dit et
je pense que chacun d'entre vous l'avez
dit d'ailleurs à l'époque
il était claire et nous l'avons répété
souvent tous ensemble que le un des
problèmes à des défauts inde et des
obstacles en fait à la bonne utilisation
des passes c'est qu'en fait ça donne un
sentiment un faux sentiment de sécurité
je vous rappelle les relations à des
gestes barrières que nous avions tous
vécu et dans douze objets qui a parlé
après le passé où il vient écouter un
peu l'orateur ça serait bien
merci de leurs résidents merci ce
sentiment d'ailleurs de de fausse
sécurité il a été un peu entretenu par
certains adoptent des déclarations du
ministre pas de vous mais du ministre
verra talent d'abord par la noce à un
moment donné de la fin de l'obligation
du masque en intérieur en eux rpd la
mise en oeuvre du passani terre on est
vite revenu sur cette mesure où
heureusement ensuite des déclarations un
peu trop peu celle du 22 décembre je
vous le rappelle on est basique c'est le
ministre qui parle on veut que quelqu'un
qui rentre au resto se disent les gens
qui sont autour de moi surtout se
protéger donc j'enlève mon masque je
peux manger je risque que rien au micro
ou pas au micro c'est une déclaration du
ministère se passait pas une invention
de ma part d'une fac news donc on voit
bien qu'il ya un relâchement des gestes
barrières à partir du groupe à où il ya
eu le passage du ter et bateleurs qui
aura un relâchement des gestes barrières
avec le pass vaccinale c'est un danger
c'est un danger pour la propagation du
virus il est bien là et si le vaccin à
toute son utilité pour éviter les formes
graves et pour permettre une guérison
plus sûr et plus rapide les gestes
barrière eux sont le pilier de la lutte
contre les contagions et doivent être
reconnus comme ceux qu'ils sont
essentiels dans la lutte contre cette
pandémie il est dommage de laisser
croire que vacciner les gens peuvent
s'en passer il est important que cela
soit affirmée et c'est l'objet de notre
amendement japonais et le rapporteur
tous ces amendements monsieur le
président ils vont dans ce sens une
meilleure sécurité sanitaire donc la
seule question qui se pose c'est est-ce
que les modalités qu'il comporte sont
les plus efficaces sur un plan
strictement opérationnels c'est pas un
débat idéologique que nous allons avoir
il me semble que les décisions prises
par le gouvernement ne sont pas les plus
faciles à expliquer et les plus
pertinentes chiffres de quelques
milliers de personnes applicable quels
que soient la capacité d'accueil une
salle de spectacle ou d'un stade
franchement ça n'a pas grand sens parce
que si vous prenez le stade rennais avec
ses 30000 places et breton le savent
bien et vous le comparez avec le stade
vélodrome avec ses soixante sept mille
places appliquer la même jauge dans les
deux stades et je ne parle même pas des
80000 places du stade de france où des
60000 places de lyon ou des 50000 places
du parc des princes mais ça n'est pas la
même chose et encore s'il y avait deux
stades de la même dimension faudrait-il
tenir compte du nombre d'accès parce que
c'est au moment où on rentrait où on
sort du stade que les risques de
promiscuité sont les plus grands si bien
que il me semble que ça n'est pas en
déplaçant le chiffre d'une jauge qu'on
va régler le problème mais en fixant
dans le texte une
hinault qui revient à dire que on doit
déterminer les règles d'accès en
fonction des risques sanitaires lesquels
se mesure en fonction de la promiscuité
auquel les spectateurs vont être exposés
et c'est ce que nous avons essayé de
faire à la commission des lois nous
avons écrit que la réglementation pour
l'accès aux salles de spectacle et au
stade est adapté à la situation
sanitaire ça va de soi et prend en
compte les caractéristiques des
établissements concernés grands ou
petits j'ai grand ou petit c'est moi
qu'ils ajoutent notamment leur
configuration
nombreux de lieux d'accès pour tenir
compte des dangers concours en faisant
la queue et leur capacité d'accueil
nombre de spectateurs dans les
conditions propres à limiter les risques
de contamination ça ça veut dire dans
les conditions propres à éviter la
promiscuité qui créent des risques de
contamination du coup si vous nous
suivez vous ne ferez pas ces amendements
non pas parce qu'ils sont mauvais dans
leur principe mais parce que finalement
le plus efficace c'est de définir la
règle dans le texte plutôt que de donner
un chiffre dans le texte qui sera
valable ici et pas là même si ce chiffre
est plus pertinente les chiffres retenus
par le gouvernement avis donc
défavorable pour ces amendements à
montrent leurs auteurs veuillent bien
les retirer si j'ai réussi à les
convaincre dimanche le ministre
merci monsieur le président je
commencerai si vous me autorisé par le
dernier le 106 de monsieur benarroch
pour lui dire que celui ci est satisfait
donc lui proposer de le retirer les 7 c
est dans les faits parce que mise en
place d jamais est évidemment dans
l'intention du gouvernement de renoncer
aux gestes barrières qu'il s'agit du
port du masque ou la distanciation des
eaux
et règles d'hygiène et que par ailleurs
dans la sas et dans les faits dans la
loi la loi du 31 mai 2021 dans sa
rédaction qui est issue de celle du 5
août 2021 comporte déjà des dispositions
analogues à celles que vous proposez
donc c'est sûr le 106 je vous propose
donc de le retirer si ce n'est de le
défaut ce sera défavorable pardon sur
les autres sur les autres amendements
sera également un avis défavorable de la
part de la part du gouvernement jean
temps j'ai entendu parler notamment dans
l'argumentaire de monsieur lévy de
simplicité des règles se passe sur
s'agissant de son amendement sérieux 36
rectifié qu'imposer une jauge
additionnel de 50 % dans les stades et
salles de spectacles ayant une capacité
d'accueil supérieure respectivement 5
mille à deux mille personnes bref pour
l'assistante de critères soient
forcément gage de simplicité
dans les dispositions que nous mettons
en place est de la même façon imposer un
système proportionnel qui peut
apparaître comme de bon sens comme étant
plus simple là aussi méfions-nous des
apparences cette approche au prorata se
présente comme simple alors qu'elle peut
être éminemment complexe à mettre en
oeuvre en réalité dans les faits
présentant des difficultés de contrôle
et ont exposé à des débats et des
contentieux sur le calcul des surfaces
ou des capacités à prendre en compte en
second lieu le prorata peut se révéler
inappropriées au regard de la diversité
des configurations des établissements
qui reçoivent du public qui font que
deux établissements qui ont les mêmes
capacités d'accueil peuvent présenter
des risques sanitaires différents selon
les phase épidémique selon les
caractéristiques des variants contre
lesquelles nous cherchons à lutter et
enfin et surtout peut-être un prorata
imposé en toutes circonstances ne peut
que nuire à la vraie proportionnalité
que je crois nous recherchons tous c'est
d'ailleurs le rapporteur qui leur
rappelait et qui doit reposer sur une
approche plus fine bien souvent
multicritères contextualiser une
approche qui amène au constat qu'il vaut
mieux parfois une jauge unique simples
claires compréhensibles pour certaines
catégories de nerf et un moment donné
plutôt qu'à un ratio qui soit sujet à
toutes les controverses en amont ou en
aval dans le cadre d'un contentieux
voilà pour toutes ces raisons le
gouvernement souhaite rester au
dispositif initialement proposé donc
porte un avis défavorable sur ces
amendements si monsieur guy laroche
je dois avouer que j'ai pas très bien
compris en fait ce que nous a dit le
ministre à l'instant où nous explique la
proportionnalité c'est compliqué il faut
l'adapter aux configurations et que donc
à partir du moment où il faut l'adapter
aux configurations et à la capacité
c'est plus simple de fixer une chose
unique sans tenir compte ni des
configurations ni de la capacité donc
j'y comprends pas ce raisonnement je
suis désolé bon voilà donc je continue à
défendre cet amendement et pourrait pas
d'un autre à porter monsieur le
rapporteur je serais d'accord avec vous
à une condition c'est qu'effectivement
les capacités soient fixés après une
concertation qu'ils aient lieu avec le
préfet avec le préfet avec les clubs
avec les supporteurs avec les élus etc
avant de prendre le décret la mesure or
en tout cas dans mon département je le
regrette mais en général le préfet
continue colloque c'est pas pour nous
demander un avis mais c'est pour les
informer des décisions qu'il a déjà
prises donc vous auriez raison ou vous
aurait accepté mon autre amendement qui
va arriver après qui dit il faut qu'une
concertation préalable et que les pistes
de décision soit informé par le préfet
auprès des parlementaires je vous aurais
dit vous avez raison mais tel que vous
le défendez je pense que vous avez très
bien défendu nos amendements et non pas
le fait de les rejeter donc je pense qu
prenant aux côtes votre démonstration
nous ne pouvons que voter les
amendements que nous défendons monsieur
lévis madame robert et moi même donc je
réponds dans ces deux sens et donc je
maintiens les deux amendements et je
vous demande de les voter
merci mais c'est pas cher
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues j'ai bien écouté notre
rapporteur et j'entends que la
commission a bien pris soin
d'améliorer largement le texte du
gouvernement
lui égard aux décisions absurdes qui ont
été prises jusqu'à présent et chers
collègues pour ceux qui veulent un
exemple je les invite à aller voir les
images d'un match de football qui a eu
lieu pendant les fêtes avec lens lille
où vous aviez quelques milliers de
personnes mais étaient tous regroupés
ensemble avec l'ensemble du stade vide
car voilà la mesure absurde que l'on
arrive à prendre lorsque c'est vrai que
ça ne fait que deux ans maintenant que
nous avons le que vides et qu on ne sait
toujours pas gérer des jauges au
gouvernement donc je suis très heureux
que la commission précise les choses
mais je trouve que l'amendement notre
collègue lévy piratins de lévis va
vraiment plus encore dans ce sens et
j'aime sa précision c'est pourquoi pour
une fois je ne suivrai pas le rapporteur
et j'espère qu'il ne m'en voudra pas je
trouve que cette précision 50% est la
bienvenue car j'entends monsieur le
rapporteur que vous dites que c'est au
moment où il ya les accès on peut se
contaminer mais je vous rassure on se
contamine tout autant en faisant la
queue aux pharmacies pour se faire
tester matin et soir vous avez plus
d'une heure de queue trois heures de
queue dans mon département dans certains
laboratoires pour aller se faire tester
donc c'est une autre façon de faire qui
a inventé le gouvernement par ces
précisions je pense que nous serons
frère un peu mieux merci monsieur polio
monsieur le ministre je suis assez
surpris par votre réponse vous vous
dites on veut quelque chose et c'est la
position du gouvernement de claire de
précis et d'indiscutable vous n'avait à
aucun moment répondu à la question que
je vous ai posé en quoi une jauge de
10000 qui est claire précise et est
constante et elle pose plus de problèmes
qu une jauge de 5000 je crois que ça
serait intéressant que vous puissiez
nous expliquer comment et je rejoins ce
que vient de dire notre collègue c'est
que souvent il ya il ya des phénomènes
où les personnes sont regroupées dans
des parties de dans des parties de stade
et que par rapport à cela je rappelle
tous les efforts qui ont été faits pour
répondre aux demandes du gouvernement
par les organisateurs donc visant à
interdire les buvettes visant à faire de
telle sorte que les hospitalités se
fasse à six et non plus deux bouts donc
dans ce cadre là il n'y a pas de
difficultés et vous n'allez pas non plus
répondu à la question que je vous ai
posé par rapport aux précédentes
contraintes qui ont été celles voulues
par le gouvernement au travers de ces
jeunes ça eu des conséquences
économiques pour lesquels le
gouvernement s'était engagé de les
compenser intégralement
aujourd'hui il reste toujours 25
millions d'euros donc qui n'ont pas été
versés au club de rugby la question que
je vous pose monsieur le ministre c'est
de savoir tendre allez vous verser ces
sommes là et comment voulez vous qu'on
vous fasse confiance sur nouveau schéma
alors que pour l'ancien je veux dire les
éléments de compensation n'ont pas été
apportées comme il comme le gouvernement
s'y était engagé donc ça nous interpelle
par rapport à ça pour ces raisons
monsieur le président je maintiens mon
amendement
avait pas de demande de retrait
d'ailleurs
madame robert
oui rapidement monsieur ministre en fait
ce que vous avez répondu c'est
exactement ce qui a été répandu à
l'assemblée nationale puisque vous êtes
très bien que c'est un amendement qui
était passé en commission d'une chose le
premier vous dit ce n'est pas possible
de mettre en oeuvre ou ce sera compliqué
pouvez vous expliquer pourquoi ce serait
plus compliqué et la deuxième chose que
ce serait source de contentieux si l'on
prend en compte justement par notre
amendement est d'ailleurs monsieur
ménard roche l'a dit le fait que les
réalités territoriales par le pouvoir
réglementaire et par l'idée de concerter
avec les élus le préfet pour que en
fonction de la configuration et la
capacité d'accueil y ait cette
proportionnalité qui s'applique je pense
qu'au contraire non seulement en prend
en compte les spécificités territoriales
mais on est attentif à la configuration
et à la capacité des lieux et on
applique la proportionnalité des
capacités d'accueil justement en la
matière donc je trouve que ce serait un
complément intéressant à l'amendement
qui a été proposé par le rapporteur et
ça permettrait en tout cas de mettre les
élus dans la boucle et que ceux ci
puissent être également en tout cas
concernés par le sujet je vous remercie
ces genres collègue monsieur lévy
oui monsieur le président désolé
monsieur le rapporteur vous ne m'avez
pas convaincu et donc je vais bien sûr
maintenir mon amendement je me dis j'ai
du mal à comprendre effectivement pour
il est très compliqué de calculer une
jauge maximale sachant que toutes les
tous les stades ont une capacité
d'accueil et cette proportionnalité les
très facile de la calcul est donc de
donner à l'organisateur du match le
nombre de passes qui peut vendre et
c'est aussi difficile de contrôler le
nombre de places est jose finalement que
les 2000 personnes je vous n'avez pas
plus de chances qu'ils soient réellement
respecter ou pas donc cette
proportionnalité va venir justement
régler des absurdités notamment celles
que l'on a vues je rappelle ce qu'a dit
jérôme bascher lors du match le dernier
match de lens puisque les 5000
spectateurs est exactement dans la même
tribune pour des raisons d'économie
puisque quand on met tous les
spectateurs dans une tribune
ça évite de mettre des stadiers dans
tout le stade et comme déjà il perd
beaucoup d'argent les clubs
professionnels et les essaye d'en
économiser comme ils peuvent donc moi je
ne comprends pas votre raisonnement que
j'administre donc bien évidemment cet
amendement ainsi que celui de monsieur
de folio viennent essayer d'aider les
clubs professionnels à perdre le moins
d'argent possible et pourquoi faire
payer à l'état finalement ce que sont
capables de payer des jambes ce qu'ils
veulent voir un match ils sont vaccinés
puisque vous voulez refuser l'accès au
stade des personnes non vaccinées donc
au stade de france je pense qu'on peut
mettre quarante mille personnes sans
aucune difficulté donc moi je maintiens
cet amendement et j'espère qu'il sera
voté si chaque collègue monsieur
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre est actuellement ce que vient
de dire notre collègue pourquoi en
réalité cette règle de 5000 elle et elle
et elle est un peu absurde parce qu un
stade où il ya 40 ou 50 me place si vous
avez cinq mille personnes vous perdez de
l'argent vous n'avez pas l'hospitalité
ni les buvettes qu'est ce que vous
faites vous ouvrez qu'une tribune de
5000 places et donc il n'y a aucun écart
d'un siège sur deux alors que si on y va
sur la proportionnalité à 50% en 10 ans
on ouvre l'entière entièrement les
stades quelle que soit la capacité
qu'elle soit 2 10 20 50 ou 80 milles et
on n'impose qu'un truc une personne ou
un groupe de personnes qui vit ensemble
un siège d'écart et là pour le coup on
en compagnie compris les clubs à passer
cette crise et parce qu'ils perdront
évidemment 50 % des places mais c'est
bien plus compréhensible à mon avis
comme ça que ce que nous imposons 5000
places dans un stade de 5000 ou 6000
places dans un centre de 80000
évidemment le stade de 60 ou 80 milles
va pas ouvert l'ensemble du stade et
alors qui va perdre beaucoup beaucoup
d'argent donc on devrait là aussi je
crois écouter les clubs et apprendre de
la crise que nous venons de vivre depuis
deux ans pour se dire que refaire cette
jauge de 5000 n'est pas efficace et
n'est pas tenable économies économies
tant est que nous pouvons proposer autre
chose à l'ensemble des clubs et des
supporters des supportrices convient
aussi de vivre des moments un peu de
solidarité de fraternité et de
divertissement dans cette période je
vous remercie collègue monsieur chasse a
précisé le ministre effectivement je
pense que il faut quand même bien sûr
faire attention parce que
on a
une contagion
extraordinaire avec le varia un micro ou
mais je pense que ce que met en place ce
que propose m en place monsieur lévy
alors peut-être ça peut être amélioré
mais moi je voterai cet amendement
[Musique]
oui mais c'est le président je soutiens
évidemment pleinement la proposition du
sénateur levin et au delà j'aimerais si
ce n'est aujourd'hui dans les jours qui
viennent que soient clarifiées
effectivement la question a été posée la
situation des clubs professionnels que
ce soit le rugby que ce soit le football
hockey sur glace je pense en particulier
à mon club des hautes-alpes les rapaces
agapes qui se retrouve dans une
situation à cause des restrictions qui
devient catastrophique et il n'y a pas
eu à ce jour les compensations
nécessaires d'accompagnement pour
pouvoir sauvegarder non seulement ces
clubs professionnels mais aussi et
surtout toute la dynamique éducative qui
tourne autour de ces clubs dont je crois
qu'il y est il y à un ciel d'alarmé à la
lancée et j'attends effectivement la
part du gouvernement des réponses dans
les prochains jours si ce n'est ce soir
merci si monsieur le rapporteur
ce président je ne défends pas que le
football se défend aussi le rugby je
tenais quand même à le dire parce que ma
première intervention n'était pas
complète sur ce point deuxièmement mes
chers collègues je vais exactement dans
votre sens et je me permets de vous
signaler que si vos amendements ont été
adoptés vous vous seriez tirer une balle
dans le pied tout simplement parce que
quand vous dites que la george doit être
proportionnelle à la capacité d'accueil
et que vous le fixer aucune proportion
le gouvernement aura les mâts
entièrement libre il pourra décider 5%
de la capacité d'accueil 10% 15% 20% il
fera juridiquement c'est obligatoire
exactement ce qu'il voudra donc les deux
amendements qui sont ainsi rédigé sont
des amendements qui donne les pleins
pouvoirs au gouvernement pour fixer
l'âge anges dans les stades aussi bien
pour le rugby que pour le fun balle donc
je voudrais vraiment insister sur ce
point si vous vous avez présenté des
amendements qui sont moins contraignant
pour le gouvernement que la position que
je vous ai rappelé tout à l'heure qui
consiste à dire que on doit tenir compte
des risques de promiscuité en fonction
de la configuration et la capacité
d'accueil du stade en cause quant aux
deux autres amendements qui fixent eux
mêmes une jauge je redis que fixer une
jauge dans la loi c'est une erreur car
ça aboutit nécessairement a traité de la
même façon le stade de rennes et le
stade de france alors qu'ils n'ont pas
la même capacité d'accueil j'insiste
beaucoup sur ce point en vérité quelle
que soit la mandement que vous voterez
et bien que vous ne voterez pas plutôt
ça n'est pas au coeur de notre
discussion législative mais ce que je
vous dis c'est dans l'intérêt même des
porteurs de ces amendements parce que je
voudrais que effectivement leur
intention trouve une traduction
efficiente efficace opérationnel dans la
loi et je trouve que la moins mauvaise
solution c'est quand même celle que nous
avons retenue elle est contraignante
pour le gouvernement merci monsieur le
ministre et quelques éléments de réponse
sur le président merci à monsieur
sénateurs folio tout d'abord vous êtes
là bas à la fin de ce sénateur pourquoi
pas dix mille vision d'une parce que ce
n'est pas dans la loi et pour des
raisons exposées notamment par le
rapporteur c'est bien au niveau du
décret qu'aujourd'hui le seuil de 5000 a
été déféré et pourquoi pas 15 milles et
puis peut-être demain 2000 en réalité en
fonction de l'évolution de la situation
sanitaire donc ne nous figeons pas oui
mais mais mais même à l'extérieur mais
mais certes l extérieur en extérieur
mais enfin que vous l'avez dit vous-même
je crois dans votre propos il ya un
certain nombre d'activités
sociales etc fort heureux qui ont lieu
même dans une enceinte sportive et dans
ce cadre là aussi la circulation du
virus à alieu donc gardons nos
rigidifiant par les règles
la question de ces pas une question de
laisser une fois encore les mains libres
événement c'est simplement être en
capacité de pouvoir s'adapter à la
situation sanitaire madame la sénatrice
vous n'êtes pas là pardon madame excusez
moi sur les éléments que vous avez
mis en avant et est fixé des jeunes on
fera en fonction des spécificités de
chaque établissement qui reçoit du
public la surface
sa configuration
très concrètement ça veut dire quoi nous
projetons nous très concrètement ça veut
dire que le préfet dans chaque
territoire va devoir se rendre dans
chaque établissement qui reçoit du
public va donc et on va devoir donc
émettre des centaines de milliers
d'actes individuels pour pour chaque
établissement
mais si
monsieur le rapporteur la réalité la
réalité c'est ça mais non mais vous vous
on peut rester dans la théorie la
réalité c'est que les préfets vont
devoir les se rendent dans chaque 1er
fait pour aller voir quelle est la
surface et puis il va avoir des
discussions sur la surface qu'on doit
prendre en compte même si c'est ça la
réalité et comment la configuration et
et fait donc on peut mobiliser si vous
voulez les des centaines de
fonctionnaires préfectoraux et plus
encore pour aller faire ce travail mais
la réalité c'est là donc je pense pas
que ça soit une approche qui soit non
mais c'est ça la réalité monsieur
benarroch c'est ça la réalité si on
adopte ce genre de dispositif bon sur
les fameuses images de lille lens ou de
lens lille je sais plus qui était qui
recevait cet élan ce bon
tous étaient un peu surpris
effectivement de voir ses 5000
supporters dans la même tribune soyez
rassurés sur les ont convaincus et vous
le savez
depuis plusieurs mois dans les
protocoles il est inscrit que ce type de
situation ne doit pas arriver et la
ministre des sports a rappelé et
rappellent sans cesse et après cet
événement que dans les protocoles il est
écrit que ce type de configuration et
d'organisations publiques ne doit pas
avoir lieu la ministre des sports l'a
encore rappelé aux exploitants des clubs
et des stades récemment suite à à 7 à
cet événement enfin
quand je râle du sport vous dire quand
même que le miz des sports et les miss
de l'économie sont évidemment attentifs
à soutenir les clubs sportifs notamment
face aux difficultés financières qui
peuvent recevoir je suis un peu étonné
d'entendre dire que rien n'est fait
comme ça vient d'être dit au bénéfice
des des clubs sportifs je pense que
c'est assez loin de là de la réalité et
entend rappeler quand même que la
discussion que nous avons pour conclure
un lieu dans le cadre d'une situation
sanitaire ou plus de trois cent mille de
nos concitoyens
sont contaminées chaque jour c'est quand
même ça encore la situation aujourd'hui
est que dans un certain nombre de pays
voisin du nôtre les établissements dont
nous parlons là ils sont fermés
ils sont tout simplement fermé voilà
donc la politique mise en place par le
gouvernement avec les règles qui sont
proposés permettent le maintien de
l'activité permettent de pouvoir
s'adapter au plus près à l'évolution de
la situation sanitaire permettent de
concilier à la fois la sécurité des
français et la poursuite de l'activité
économique des uns et des autres avec le
soutien nécessaire parce que les uns et
les autres auront effectivement un
certain nombre de difficultés voilà
monsieur le président pour ces quelques
éléments devraient encore une demande
d'intervention et puis ensuite on passe
au vote le cheveu bonus
pourquoi vous attendez pas là c'est bon
j'ai une question est ce qu'on va
évaluer les conséquences de cette
décision sur les clubs sportifs
professionnels les conséquences
aujourd'hui un stade à 5000 méthodes
comme lyon comme lyon psg ça me dit
commune l'ol a perdu quand on reçoit ce
ministre ce ministre ce ministre quand
on reçoit 5000 personnes sur
installations pardon
quand on reçoit 5000 personnes
non il faudrait mettre correctement
sur l'honneur à ça quand on reçoit 5000
personnes sur salat 110000 j'ai eu le
président de l'ol les conséquences
financières sont énormes vous savez dans
les galeries marchandes chaque week-end
il y en a il y en a cent mille qui
rentrent ce week-end à toulon y en a 200
milles qui sont rentrés sur les oreilles
d'or qui me l'a dit aujourd'hui nous
avons des stades vides des stades vides
qui et qui malheureusement nos clubs
chaque fois qu'il faut un match il
perdre d'argent considérables et ça veut
pas être rattrapé moi je souhaite
sincèrement je vais voter l'amendement
de monsieur lévy parce que je le
trouvais juste et loyal vis-à-vis d'un
autre professionnel son rugby foot ou
autre ou attendez ou autres disciplines
merci chers collègues donc je mets
nouveau à l'amendement 36 avec deux avis
défavorables de la commission du
gouvernement qui est pour
je vais vous demander de vous lever ceux
qui sont pour se lève c'est plus facile
[Musique]
c'est ça dans le top
ça ne tient plus
merci vous pouvez vous asseoir que ceux
qui sont contre se lève
[Musique]
je pense que vous pouvez vous asseoir
que ceux qui s'abstiennent se lève
merci merci l'amendement est adopté et
donc si il fait tomber
il fait tomber les quatre autres
amendements nous allons maintenant
prendre 10 amendements identiques si
vous prouvez que l'un ne rate un orateur
avant vous l'a très bien présente et
n'hésitez pas à dire qu'il est défendu
je ne commence par madame de ces trocs
avec le set rectifié bis
temps d oui merci madame la présidente
cet amendement vise à supprimer les
dispositions relatives à la vérification
d'identité lors de la présentation du
futur passe vaccinale si la fraudeuse
ces documents sur ces documents doit
être sévèrement combattu et punis ces
dispositions viennent renforcer le
sentiment de défiance à l'égard des
français la pratique du contrôle
d'identité ou de la vérification de la
concordance d'identité est strictement
encadrée dans notre droit dans une
logique de protection des libertés
individuelles et repose principalement
sur les forces de l'ordre formés à cet
effet le régime de sortie de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire actuellement en
vigueur ne justifie pas d'étendre cette
vérification
pour ces deux motifs il convient de
laisser cette tâche aux autorités dont
c'est le métier les forces de l'ordre
merci
on continue avec madame miller bran
défendu
on
continue avec madame après monsieur
fabien gay
merci madame la présidente monsieur vis
mes chers collègues dans un moment
important
sur la question du contrôle
nous l'avions dit sur la question du
passé ni terre nous avions redis notre
opposition et il y avait déjà la
question
d'y ajouter une pièce d'identité et nous
l'avions dit à cette époque là
nous pensons pas que tout le monde doit
contrôler tout le monde et que demain
nous devions non une société de contrôle
social
où chacune et chacun qui n'est pas
habilité à contrôler les papiers
puissent le faire c'est à dire nous
allons étendre que les serveurs à les
serveuses puisse contrôler les agents de
sécurité qui le soir même agent de
sécurité vont contrôler les serveuses et
les serveurs qui vont se rendre à un
événement ou à tel concert ou un tel
stade pour aller revoir une compétition
sportive on est franchement on ne
voulons pas mettre le doigt là dedans si
nous mettons le doigt là dedans nous
aurons les plus grandes difficultés pour
revenir en arrière
donc nous pensons et nous continuons à
penser qu'il faut que ça soit les op j
qui reste et qui puisse contrôler y
compris il ya un débat sur quelle pièce
d'identité parce qu'aujourd'hui on n'est
pas obligé de présenter pièce d'identité
avec photo y compris
quelqu'un qui est avec vous peut
attester que c'est bien vous sur
l'honneur et ça fonctionne et si nous
mettons le doigt là dedans y compris
dans un doute raisonnable
je vous le dis à l'eau nous pensons dans
une autre société et ça ça nous
permettra pas de combattre efficacement
qu'au vide c'est tout autre chose comme
projet de société qui nous est proposée
par le gouvernement donc nous proposons
des évidemment de supprimer ces alinéas
je vous remercie madame noël il est
défendu
monsieur qu'est nevers
merci madame la présidente de cheminée
shackley quelques mots simplement pour
dire que ce débat dépasse bien sûr les
clivages politiques et puis suffit de se
rendre dans les établissements de
restauration pour se rendre compte
combien les tenanciers de ces
établissements ne souhaite pas
effectivement qu' il soit obligé
d'opérer des contrôles je crois que cela
relève de la responsabilité des forces
de l'ordre et la rédaction telle qu'elle
a été prévu dans le texte paraît
suffisamment flou pour justement pouvoir
induire des abus et donc ceci n'est pas
acceptable et donc il convient je crois
de remettre les choses en place
c'est-à-dire de considérer que les
contrôles relève des restes de la
responsabilité des forces de l'ordre et
pas de celle des exploitants de
l'activité commerciale
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre sur collègues c'est un
amendement important qui est identique
avec beaucoup d'autres et qui vient bien
rappeler ce qu'est le pass sanitaire
dans son caractère
proportionné est temporaire quand
j'entends 15 hommes de nos collègues ont
l'idée date d'insérer la photo
d'identité dans le pass sanitaire c'est
bien qu'ils imaginent que ce pas
sanitaire durera longtemps parce que sur
un plan technique sans aucun avis de la
cnil allait proposer que la photo
d'identité un day le pacifique c'est
quasiment faire du pain salita le en
lui-même une pièce d'identité et donc ça
c'est une grave erreur de mon point de
vue et nous ne devons pas
le passé l'été a déjà suffisamment
attentatoire aux libertés publiques j'ai
l'impression de me répéter mais c'est
bien ce que je pense pour que nous le
laissions au moins dans sa formule
actuelle y compris dans sa version pas
actional si si d'aventuré le parlement
devait voter ça mais de ne pas
en
rajouter de chose est sûre la question
du contrôle de l'identité on va donner
cette faculté à des responsables
d'établissements mais non seulement va
leur donner cette faculté au garden est
aussi une pouvoir d'appréciation c'est
quand ils se diront d'eux mêmes que ils
vont elles peut-être dans une situation
où ils vont aux devoirs appelé à
justifier qu'ils vont faire cette
démarche là or en france a été rappelé
très bien par plusieurs orateurs à
l'instant ce sont des personnes
dépositaires de l'autorité publique
jouissant de prérogatives de puissance
publique forme est inscrit dans une
hiérarchie avec un pouvoir disciplinaire
voire deux pouvant exposer aux
changements de la justice qui font des
contrôles d'identité en france ils ont
un matricule sur le sur le sur le sur
l'épaule et si vous n'êtes pas contents
d'un contrôle d'identité en france on
pouvait vous en plaindre et donc ça
c'est essentiel comment vous des quais
de recourir et vous exercez demain
vis-à-vis d'un tenancier de bar ou de
restaurants qui vous empêchera de
rentrer donc vraiment supprimer ce
contrôle d'identité qui est une très
mauvaise idée mais ses soeurs
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues j'ai dit
hier tout à l'heure dans la discussion
générale
combien cette question était importante
pour notre groupe
nous avons dit qu'il était dans la
logique de l'obligation vaccinale
de
respecter le pass
vaccinale en dépit du fait que nous
aurions préféré que notre amendement sur
l'obligation
finale fut adoptée
nous avons dit qu'il y avait pour nous
des conditions fortes en termes de
libertés publiques et c'est pourquoi je
ne vais pas développer mais l'argument
est très fort quand je vois qu'il est
dit que le restaurateur en question
devra statuer pour savoir s'il existe
des raisons sérieuses de penser
comment va-t-il penser en regardant le
visage l'apparence d'une personne qui
est là qu il va falloir quand même lui
demander ses papiers d'identité
seulement dans aucune autre ne suscitera
pas la même suspicion il y a un gros
problème et je crois même un problème
constitutionnel
mes chers collègues j'ai observé que
monsieur le rapporteur philippe bas
avait été constant dans ses
appréciations et dans ses convictions
sur l'ensemble des sujets entre hier et
aujourd'hui sauf sur ce sujet ou son
appréciation à évoluer et j'espère de
tout coeur que cela rappelle que cela
nous permettra d'avoir une position très
claire sur la répartition des rôles
entre des commerçants restaurateurs etc
et les forces de police et de
gendarmerie faux chacun accomplisse son
office monsieur benarroch
si mes collègues d'avoir brillamment
défendu ces amendements identiques est
similaire
cette mesure en elle même porte le
principe d'un contrôle d'identité
réalisés par des personnes non
habilitées à le faire et qui plus est
qu'il ne souhaite pas effectuer ce
contrôle en leur laissant plus libre
appréciation à leur discrétion totale
des critères selon lesquels ils
pourraient ou pas contrôler ses papiers
cette mesure en fait participe de fait à
l'instauration d'un contrôle social
généralisé de la population de
l'installation d'un nouveau modèle
sociale et d'un nouveau modèle de
société qui est contraire aux valeurs de
beaucoup d'entre nous qui est contraire
aux valeurs de notre démocratie et qui
est contraire aussi aux valeurs de notre
groupe elle fut enfin aussi nous ne
l'avons pas dit par son principe même
par la façon dont la le pouvoir
discrétionnaire et donner à certains qui
ne le souhaitent pas d'ailleurs conduire
à des phénomènes de violence de trouble
de l'ordre public et à un certain nombre
d'incivilités qui peuvent devenir assez
grave donc nous vous demandons
sincèrement de bien vouloir accepter de
considérer les arguments des différents
intervenants et devient vouloir voter
ces amendements de telle façon à ce que
nous n'allions pas vers une dérive de
notre constitution la boulette péronier
il est défendu adam mend à sa
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre collègues les règles
définissant le cadre d'un contrôle
d'identité sont établis par l'article
78-2 du code pénal seuls les officiers
agents et agents adjoint de police
judiciaire peuvent le réaliser or la
viabilité du pass vaccinale dépend
grandement de son contrôle le texte
adopté par l'assemblée nationale
permettez d'octroyer aux personnes en
charge de ce contrôle le droit
d'effectuer non pas un contrôle
d'identité
mais je suis une vérification de
concordance documentaire si cette astuce
lexical n'a pas été conservé par la
commission des lois du sénat le
dispositif proposé par celle ci reste
tout de même club les matic le texte
laisse toujours la possibilité aux
personnes chargées du contrôle du pass
vaccinale d'effectuer un contrôle
d'identité
ce transfert de compétence de la police
vers la société civile n'est pas
acceptable comment se prémunir de
possibles discriminations
comment éviter les abus volontaire ou
non de la part de ceux qui doivent
contrôler une grande majorité d'entre
nous for many qualifié pour cela
ajoutons à cela que l'aspect chronophage
d'un tel contrôle plus que le simple
scan d'un qr code peut rendre ce
contrôle d'identité difficile à réaliser
dans certains établissements
cette question du contrôle de l'identité
ne semble être qu'un détail dans le
débat pour le gouvernement cela ne l'est
pas pour beaucoup de nos concitoyennes
et concitoyens qui souffrent
quotidiennement des abus liés à cette
procédure c'est aussi pour cela que je
demande sa suppression mairie
merci madame benbassa nous en avons donc
fini avec ces amendements identiques le
153 monsieur guay je crois par six
minutes dernier argument cher collègue
vous savez combien il faut de temps pour
former un officier de police judiciaire
ces 18 heures pourquoi
parce que la police
c'est les seuls à qui nous confions la
violence légitime de l'état et nous
l'acceptons pas ce qu'est un contrat
social c'est les seuls qui peuvent nous
contraindre nous arrêtent et nous
demandait le papier
18 mois de formation d'ailleurs nous
avons un débat entre nous il faudrait
l'augmenter cette formation de nos
policiers nos policière et formé plus au
pgi qui manque dans nos commissariats
temps aujourd'hui mais si demain si
demain nous vantons ça peut nous
permettons à chacune et chacun en
l'espace d'une nuit de devenir officier
de police judiciaire et de pouvoir
contrôler tout le monde
mais imaginez un seul instant qu'elle
manque de discernement parce
qu'évidemment certains le feront bien
mais nous allons donner un petit pouvoir
sans formation à des centaines de
milliers de personnes et ce sont des
abus qui va voir mais ce sont aussi les
mettre en danger les difficultés parce
qu'ils ne seront pas formés à pouvoir
faire ce contrôle en toute sécurité
mais oui vous pouvez le dire mais si la
personne refuse de s'y soumettre parce
qu'il ya un doute légitime qu'est ce qui
va se passer on va faire peser sa sur
nos restaurateurs sur les agents de
sécurité de tels événements donc prenons
bien attention et je redis si nous
mettons le doigt là dedans nous aurons
la plus grande difficulté à la sortie de
la gestion de la crise sanitaire de
pouvoir en sortir et de retirer ce droit
acquis nous l'avons confié un soir en
plein milieu de semaine jours au mexique
merci monsieur richard 983
en peu de mots il nous semble que le
dispositif qui permet simplement de
vérifier s'il y a bien concordance entre
les mots le nom et la date de naissance
de la personne qui surpasse vaccinale
est la pièce d'identité se suffit à elle
même et que ce n'est pas une bonne idée
monsieur le rapporteur de vouloir
introduire et la compo la compte la
comparaison avec d'autres pièces parce
que la carte d'identité ou passeport
naturellement il a une photo récente et
une faute aux normes et il a une date de
naissance il me semble donc que d'aller
chercher d'autres documents qu'ils
soient n'ont pas la date de naissance
sur des photos qui sont hors des normes
qui peuvent être qu'ils peuvent dater de
25 ans
était n'est pas une n'est pas un
avantage il vaut mieux s'en tenir à mon
avis aux
donc les identités officiel
merci monsieur richard nous allons
maintenant donner la parole aux
rapporteurs pour qu'il nous donne son
avis sur tous ses amendements
madame la présidente mon avis celui
plutôt de la commission des lois sur
l'amendement 178 est le même que son
avis sur le 189 de monsieur ravier car
tous deux fixe un âge en deçà duquel on
ne demanderait que le pass vaccinale et
au delà duquel on pourrait demander non
en deçà duquel on ne demanderait que le
pass sanitaires et au delà duquel on
pourrait demander le pass vaccinale je
voudrais dire que le critère d'âge qui
soit fixe à 40 ou 50 ans n'est
probablement pas pertinent sur le plan
médical car ce n'est pas ni 50 ni 40 un
tournant significatif
dans le risque sanitaire ça ne prend pas
en compte les critères de comorbidité
qui peuvent justifier une attention
particulière pour une partie de la
population exposée à un risque plus
grand que les autres et puis enfin et ce
n'est pas un détail c'est quand même
très difficile à appliquer dans les
cafés et les restaurants quand on voit
arriver un client de se demander si
l'a45 en 44 ans 39 52 et ceci est donc
une source de complexité c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous avons émis un avis
défavorable à ces deux amendements nous
avons également émis un avis défavorable
à l'amendement
184 rectifié de monsieur richard
puisqu'il rétabli en réalité le
dispositif que nous avons voulu modifier
qui était proposée par le gouvernement
s'agissant maintenant de l'amendement
numéro
56 rectifié bis
c'est un des amendements d'une catégorie
qu'on pourrait qualifier catégorie de
l'effeuillage de l'artichaut du pass
vaccinale autrement dit on retirerait
secteur d'activité par secteur
d'activité feuille à feuille tous
roux une grande partie des lieux où le
passé vaccinale serait exigée et puis
finalement si on adoptait toute cette
série d'amendements on se rendrait
compte qu'il ya plus de passes vaccinale
bout à peu de choses près c'est bien sûr
le danger le risque sanitaire qui doit
être pris en compte et non pas la nature
des lieux sportives culturelles
et commerciales
qui doivent l'être et donc l'amendement
numéro 56 rectifié bis pour cette raison
puisque il vise seulement les lieux de
culture et d'établissements qui seraient
les habits sont culturelles qui seraient
exonérés de la présentation du pass
sanitaire a reçu un avis défavorable
même chose pour l'amendement suivante 57
puisque lui s'intéresse aux activités
sportives qui seraient exonérés de la
présentation d'un pass vaccinale c'est
encore une fois le danger qui compte
avis défavorable avis également
défavorable à l'amendement qui va au
delà des souplesses pourtant très grande
que la commission des lois a décidé
d'apporter s'agissant des exigences
s'imposant aux mineurs de 18 ans l'encré
un système 5 qui est d'ailleurs déjà en
vigueur parce sanitaire seulement en
dessous de 18 ans pour les différentes
sorties de ces jeunes et passe vaccinale
au delà et cet amendement propose de
supprimer aussi le pass sanitaires pour
les mineurs je tiens quand même à
souligner que deux il ya une exigence de
sécurité sanitaire pour eux aussi à ce
que on applique au moins le pass
sanitaires sans exagérer dans les
exigences qui leur sont imposées suit un
amendement qui est assez
intéressant parce que plusieurs de nos
collègues on présentait peu ou prou le
même amendement c'est un amendement 272
rectifié qui a reçu un avis défavorable
aussi et qui imposeraient que le pass
and i ter soit assortie d'une
photographie d'identité et dans un
premier temps j'aurais volontiers donné
un avis favorable à cet hymne
d'amendements mais on ne peut pas le
faire d'abord pour la raison très
judicieuse indiqué par notre collègue
les loïc hervé qui représente le sénat à
la commission nationale de
l'informatique liberté mais la
photographie c'est une donnée sensible
et encore faudrait-il d'ailleurs définir
quelle est la nature de la photographie
qui pourraient figurer sur le pass
sanitaires mais au delà de ce problème
de droite pure il ya une autre question
qui n'est pas moins importante c'est le
caractère opérationnel de la mesure car
si on pouvait d'un claquement de doigts
faire en sorte que pour 53 millions de
français déjà vaccinés et qui détiennent
le pass sanitaire au titre de cette
vaccination
on pouvait modifier sur un serveur qui
n'a pas été dimensionnée pour cela les
prescriptions pour prendre en compte une
photo qui vous le savez bien en matière
informatique est quelque chose de lourd
c'est à dire qu'il prend de la place
dans les réseaux qui sont utilisés en
réalité si on adopté cet amendement qui
paraît un amendement de bon sens on
arriverait un résultat paradoxal c'est
que le pass sanitaires et le pass
vaccinale serait suspendue pendant des
semaines et peut-être même pendant des
mois c'est à dire pendant une période au
delà de laquelle le pass ne serait plus
nécessaire donc je crois que pour cette
raison de faisabilité et pour la raison
de droit qui consiste à protéger
les données sensibles on ne peut pas
accepter cet amendement quelle que soit
la tentation qu'on pourrait avoir j'ai
obligé je le regrette je regardais tout
à l'heure notre collègue le président
milon qui était très déçu de mon propos
est évidemment je comprends pourquoi
parce qu'il s'applique aussi à son
amendement numéro 60 mais encore une
fois ça n'est pas
l'intention portés par cet amendement
qui simplifierait tous nos problèmes de
contrôle de l'identité évidemment des
détenteurs qui motivent ma
la position négative de la commission ce
sont les arguments que j'ai énoncé et
qui je crois ne sont pas surmontable si
on avait pu prévoir quelques années à
l'avant ce qu'on aurait un jour à mettre
en place un pass sanitaires on aurait pu
lever sans doute ces deux objections
nous arrivons à l'amendement numéro 120
qui propose de maintenir un pass
sanitaires pour l'accès aux transports
publics régionaux
interrégionaux
alors cet amendement est contraire à la
position de la commission vous savez que
nous avons
accepté ce pass vaccinale pour les
déplacements de longue distance
par transports publics inter régionaux
mais il y a eu heureusement et ceux qui
devraient peut-être satisfaire les
objectifs des auteurs de cet amendement
des exceptions à l'exigence du pass le
texte prévoit qu'en cas d'urgence aucun
justificatif ne peut être exigée en plus
en cas d'urgence se déplacer et le texte
prévoit aussi qu'il ya des motifs
impérieux d'en familiales ou de santé
auxquels nous avons ajouté les motifs
impérieux d'ordre professionnel en
commission des lois qui permettent de
voyager
simplement avec un test de dépistage
négatif c'est à dire en réalité qui
rétablit pour ses transports le pass
sanitaires sans imposer le pass
vaccinale quand il y a ce motif
impérieux il suffit pour ça si vous avez
un motif impérieux de faire le test
d'avoir le certificat avec son qr code
vous le présenter au contrôleur de la
sncf et il ne peut pas vous sanctionnez
d'avoir pris le train vous avez
maintenant est le 43 règle donc avis
défavorable le 43 rectifié terre pour
les mêmes motifs l'avis est défavorable
quant aux 78 puisqu'il porte sur le même
sujet la vie est aussi
défavorable
s'agissant du 190e rectifier c'est
encore le même sujet et la vie est
encore
défavorable pour le 126
la vie est également défavorable car il
s'agit de la même question des
transports et alors là nous avons un
amendement le 127 qui je dois dire à une
rédaction qui mérite d'être amélioré
mais je ne voudrais pas que vous soyez
retenue dans un élan du coeur en faveur
de cet amendement en raison de cette
rédaction insuffisante que je n'ai pas
pu redresser avec ses auteurs mais que
je m'engage s'il était adopté à modifier
dans le cadre des discussions en
commission mixte paritaire il s'agit de
cet amendement numéro 127 qui prévoit
d'ajouter aux motifs
impérieux d'ordre familial de santé ou
professionnels un motif qu'ils seraient
la présentation du voyageur devant une
juridiction où le fait de asud d'assurer
les droits de sa défense en allant voir
son avocat je crois que c'est une bonne
idée que nos collègues du groupe
communiste on tue d'ajouter cette
possibilité de se déplacer avec un test
négatif sans vaccination si c'est pour
un motif de cette nature donc mon avis
favorable mais je tiens quand même au
codis il il faudra le modifier parce que
yann toute petite toute petite faiblesse
de rédaction m'a-t-on dit faisons supra
juge moi même qu'il faudrait corriger et
nous avons l'amendement numéro 79 19 qui
voudraient ajouter au motif
professionnel pour lequel on peut
voyager juste avec un test négatif la
formation nous considérons que la
formation rentre dans le motif d'ordre
professionnel et que cette précision
n'est donc pas nécessaire n'en ferait
pas un drame si vous l'adoptez quand
même nous avons maintenant le 46
rectifié quater sur la durée de validité
des tests de dépistage virologique les
auteurs de cet amendement madame noël et
plusieurs de nos autres collègues
considèrent qu' on est passé de 72
heures à 24 heures par une mesure
d'ordre administratives et voudrait
qu'on nérigean dispositions législatives
la durée de validité des tests pour le
rétablir dans la durée de 72 heures la
commission souhaite s'en remettre à la
sagesse de notre assemblée sur ce point
l'amendement 157 veut supprimer la
possibilité d'imposer un pass sanitaires
pour l'accès aux établissements de santé
sociaux et médico-sociaux l'avis est
défavorable
le 47 rectifié bis est également
contraire à la position de la commission
la vie est également défavorable le
deux sans trois c'est le mien j'ai déjà
dit que c'était un amendement de
coordination le 159 de madame assassiné
de plusieurs de ses collègues vise à
faciliter l'accès aux soins
psychiatriques et psychologiques
pour mieux protéger les personnes
vulnérables
et
je voudrais dire que cet amendement
n'est pas nécessaire en réalité parce
qu'il existe déjà une exception en cas
d'urgence pour l'accès à ces
établissements dont les personnes pour
être soigné même si elles ne sont pas
vaccinés quand l amendement numéro 26 il
supprime la possibilité de maintenir le
pass sanitaires pour les mineurs c'est
donc contraire à la position de la
commission l'avis est défavorable
le numéro 125 rectifié prévoit qu' il
faut présenter un test négatif pour
l'accès aux établissements et les
services sociaux et médico-sociaux notre
collègue monsieur chassaing l'a fort
bien présenter tout à l'heure en
expliquant qu'il fallait ajouter à la
protection liés à la vaccination
une protection dans l'intérêt des
pensionnaires qui serait une protection
liée à un test négatif donc en
cumulerait
la bleue passe vaccinale plus le test
négatif comme dans les discothèques mais
nous avons considéré que en dépit de
l'intérêt du point de vue de l'épidémie
et de la protection contre l'épidémie
des résidents de ces établissements il
fallait aussi prendre en compte la
nécessité des visites et que malgré tout
si ces personnes sont vaccinées que
leurs visiteurs sont aussi vacciner on
peut quand même considérer que la
protection est bonne rien n'est pire
pour nos personnes âgées nous en avons
dans nos propres familles et nous le
savons parce que nous l'avons
personnellement expérimenté que cette
solitude qui vous gagne alors que votre
univers amicale s'est dégarni peu à peu
qu'il ne reste plus que quelques membres
de votre famille si en plus ils ne
peuvent pas vous rendre visite c'est
vraiment terrible alors nous avons donné
un avis défavorable je m'en excuse
auprès de notre collègue pour ces
raisons l'amendement 50 rectifié quater
nous ramène à un débat que nous avons
déjà eu sur les critères d'extinction du
pass vaccinale là vie est forcément eu
négatif et je dois dire que compte tenu
du vote que vous avez fait sur les
précédents amendements je crois que ça
devrait être le même vote c'est à dire
un vote négatif sur ce point pour
préserver le système de trois critères
qui nous paraît bien cerner la gravité
de la situation
pour justifier
le maintien du pass vaccinale ou au
contraire accepter ou entraîner plutôt
sage de reporter pardonnez moi il est
minuit il faut que je fasse un petit
bois pendant ce petit point ça va vous
permettre si vous le voulez bien de
rechercher le votre avis sur le 30 sept
rectifiez qui nous a échappé voilà et je
voulais vous prévenir monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues qu'il est
minuit que je vous propose de prolonger
la séance afin de permettre à la
commission et au gouvernement de
présenter leur avis sur les amendements
en discussion commune et peut-être de
commencer les opérations de vote et je
vous propose que notre façon de points à
minuit et demi pour voir si des guides
poursuivre encore un peu au delà de
minuit et demi
si le questeur soeur dit que c'est pas
mal
on devrait pouvoir
nous engager dans cette voie
pas d'autres observations
monsieur le rapporteur je vous rends la
parole merci madame la présidente le 30
sept rectifiez donc c'est un avis
défavorable non pas que nous soyons
défavorable au fond mais c'est parce que
nous avons déjà intégré dans le texte
c'est
exigences il s'agit pour les personnes
qui ont une contre-indication médicale
reconnu valable de pouvoir avoir
l'équivalent du pass vaccinale c'est à
dire qu' il puisse
accéder à tous les lieux auxquels les
détenteurs du pass vaccinale peuvent
accéder
madame la présidente j'en suis je crois
aux 121
firme l121 c'est la même chose c'est les
feuillages de l'artichaut et cette fois
ce n'est plus le sport ou les lieux
culturels en général mais seulement les
médiathèques bibliothèques et musées et
je crois qu'effectivement on doit en
rester à la disposition que nous avons
prises et s'agissant des jeunes je
rappelle que seul le pass sanitaire est
demandée et non pas le pass maximale
compte tenu du vote de la commission des
lois et de votre propre vote sur cette
base nous avons maintenant l'amendement
numéro 170 rectifié bis et c'est la
question de nouveau de la photographie
qui sera intégrée sur les justificatifs
de vaccination je fais donc la même
réponse que tout à l'heure madame berthé
a présenté un amendement numéro 173 sur
le même thème sera pas étonné que je
fasse la même réponse et puis nous
passons si vous le voulez bien un
amendement numéro 177 rectifier c'est
toujours le même sujet et c'est toujours
la même réponse nous avons maintenant un
nombre élevé d'amendements identiques
le set rectifié bis le 17 19 le 51
rectifié terre le 58e 61e 71 rectifié
bis le 81 le centquatre le 164 rectifié
quater et le 168
ces amendements visent à supprimer la
possibilité de la vérification
d'identité même sur les selon les
modalités
allégée par votre commission des lois
nous avons examiné c'est cet amendement
reproduit par plusieurs de nos collègues
de plusieurs groupes et nous avons
décidé d'y donner un avis de sagesse
certes dans un premier temps nous avons
considéré que l'ampleur des fraudes tels
que le gouvernement les a décrites
justifier de facilité dans les lieux
dont l'accès est assujettie à la
présentation du pass sanitaires une
vérification
allégée de la correspondance entre le
pass sanitaire est un élément qui ne
serait pas probant devant une
juridiction
mais qui serait de nature à lever les
doutes tout de même dans la plupart des
cas qui aurait été la présentation
d'une pièce comme le permis de conduire
comme le pass navigo comme la carte
vitale comme une carte d'identité
professionnelle et nous considérions que
ceux ci devaient se faire uniquement
quand un doute évident apparaissait au
responsable de l'accueil dans ces
établissements et qu' il fallait y
mettre une condition importante qui
était l'impossibilité de relever le nom
de la personne suspectée de fraude et
l'interdiction par voie de conséquence
de tout délation et puis j'entends bien
ce débat j'ai essayé de sauver cette
mesure parce qu'il me paraissait quand
même face à la fraude nécessaire d'être
vigilant mais j'entends bien que les
inconvénients paraissent l'emporter sur
les avantages parce que au fond nos
établissements qui
doivent vérifier la détention d'un pass
sanitaire ne vont pas s'engager dans ces
vérifications spontanément même si la
loi leur en donne la permission il
considère et on peut considérer que
c'est à juste titre que ce n'est pas
leur rôle et même si nous l'inscrivons
dans la loi il est quand même doute
qu'on fasse de ces établissements et de
leurs personnels des auxiliaires de la
police du coup j'ai été convaincu que
nous pouvions faire évoluer notre
position je les dis devant la commission
des lois qui a bien voulu accepter de
s'en remettre sur ces amendements
identiques à votre sagesse en sachant
qu'elle est grande
je passe maintenant à l'amendement
numéro 153 de madame à ça si madame à ça
si je ne veux pas dire de mal de cet
amendement parce qu'en réalité si notre
avis est défavorable c'est parce qu'il
est satisfait
le numéro 183 rectifié a été présentée
par monsieur richard qui s'attend à ma
réponse de toute façon il a des chances
de tomber si les amendements pour
lesquels nous nous en remettons à la
sagesse de l'assemblée devait être
adoptée la vie sinon seraient
défavorables
enfin il y à un amendement de madame
vogel c'est l'amendement numéro 67 il
soulève une problématique sérieuse dont
nul cessons de parler aux filles des
textes que nous discutons sur les
urgences sanitaires et la gestion de la
crise sanitaire une problématique très
sérieuse c'est celle des vaccins qu'ils
ont reçue à l'étranger il est bon et la
commande est déjà là dans le ne séduit
pas cet endroit là de notre discussion
il est plus loin et on l'a pas il n'a
pas été présentée
jusqu'à présent
j'aurais tenté mais ils répondent plus
complètement mais je me réserve pour
demain oui mais je suis pas sûr qu'on se
rappelle tous donc en revanche il le me
manque votre avis sur le groupe
d'amendements identiques 85 131
bien sûr madame la présidente j'allais
justement y venir
il s'agit de la suppression de la
possibilité pour le gouvernement
d'imposer un cumul du justificatif du
statut vaccinal avec un test négatif la
vie pour le numéro 80 est défavorable et
par voie de conséquence également pour
le sang neuf le 131 et le 169 rectifier
monsieur le ministre c'est à vous pour
le même exercice
sur la dizaine d'amendements 7 rectifié
biz 17 19 51 rectifié t à 58,71 rectifié
bis
81/100 464 rectifié quater et 168
qui visait à supprimer la possibilité
pour les exploitants d'établissements de
procéder à une vérification de
concordance entre lee dans des tentes en
impasse vaccinale ou sanitaires tels
qu'at&t ce n'est pas un document
officiel et données nominatives
figureront sur se passe là aussi un avis
défavorable en ligne et en ligne avec
tout ce que j'ai pu exposer paravent et
avec les arguments que le
rapporteur a également développé avec
lequel le gouvernement est d'accord sur
un avis défavorable
enfin sur le
nom c'est un avis défavorable sur de la
part du gouvernement voilà c'était
sagesse de la part du rapporteur c'est
défavorable de la part du gouvernement
merci
sur les arguments mais effectivement
j'en arrive à une conclusion
un peu un peu plus un peu plusieurs
voilà
je pourrai mais en l'occurrence c'est le
gouvernement émet un avis défavorable
le 153 de manama celle ci
c'est un avis défavorable madame la
sénatrice monsieur richard le 183
une proposition de retrait sinon un avis
là aussi défavorable sur la question du
contrôle de concordance d'identité et la
suppression de la nécessité d'une
photographie dans le bouclement qui peut
être présenté pour une personne pour
justifier qu'elle est bien titulaire
légitime du place
la substitution du test de dépistage
négatif à l'obligation de présenter un
pass vaccinale présenté par madame noël
et qui vise donc là aussi à vider sa
substance le pass vaccinale à nos yeux
reçoit un avis négatif
je continue madame la présidente vous me
direz quand il faut que quand il faut
que je m'arrête ministre arrêté j'ai
fini ma valeur
alors nous allons donc commencer les
opérations de vote sur ces amendements
nous commençons par le 178 qu'a reçu m
monsieur daumier vous non nous convenons
en 78 qui a reçu un double avis
défavorable qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstiennent n'est
pas adopté le 184 qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission est
favorable du gouvernement qui et pour
qui compte qu'ils s'abstiennent n'est
pas adopté de 189 double avis
défavorable qui est pour qu'ils aient
compris s'abstient n'est pas adoptée
déroulèrent n'est pas ne suis pas je ne
sais pas je le rappelle que le dérouleur
j'en ai conscience oui mais là c'est
compliqué quand même
[Musique]
et
alors on y va
madame collège pdc bon moi je le vois
pas le courage c'est bon le 56 rectifié
bis d'où l'avis défavorable qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient n'est pas
adopté le 57 rectifié biz double avis
défavorable qui et pour qui et contre
qui s'abstient n'est pas adopté le sang
sont 12 rectifié double avis défavorable
pied pour qui et contre qui savent ce
n'est pas adopté le 72 d'avis
défavorables qui est pour
et qui est contre il n'est pas
exceptionnel pas adopter
le 68 rectifié quad favorable qui et
pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté de 120 double avis
défavorable qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté le 43 actifs yeter double
avis défavorable qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté le 78 double avis défavorable
qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté le 190 rectifié double avis
défavorable qui est pour
et qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté le
126 double avis défavorable qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté le 127 avis favorable de la
commission avis défavorable du
gouvernement qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté
le
79 avec un avis défavorable
du rapporteur
est défavorable du gouvernement qui et
pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient n'est pas
adopté le 46 rectifié terre un avis de
sagesse de la commission un avis
défavorable du gouvernement qui est pour
et qui est contre
on recommence
kippour
on a acquis et contre qui s'abstient il
est adopté le 157 double avis
défavorable quai pour
qui et contre me lapp sien n'est pas
adopté le 47 rectifié bis double avis
défavorable qui et pour
qui et contre s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté le 203 de la commission avec un
avis sagesse du gouvernement qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient est adopté
le 159 un double avis défavorable qui et
pour qui et contre qui s'abstient il ne
pas adopter le 26 double avis
défavorable qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté le 125 double avis
défavorable qui et pour qui et contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté le 50
rectifié waters double vie pardon
aux mais je vous en prie monsieur chasse
1 vous pouvez la faire
rétrospectivement
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
j'ai voulu simplement dire dans le 125e
actuellement nous avons des personnes
vaccinées mais qui malheureusement s'est
rendu compte que elle pouvait être
contagieuse alors qu'avant au monde au
moment où on a adopté le pass vaccinale
on pensait que ces personnes n'étaient
pas contagieuse donc j'ai simplement
voulu dire que
lorsque on gère une maison de retraite
avec un directeur avec des soignants eh
bien on est angoissé d'avoir un cluster
j'ai simplement voulu dire que pendant
quelques temps il serait bon que on
puisse avoir un test
avant c'est à dire 24 heures avant de se
rendre à vie rendent visite à ses
parents même si on a le pass d'accident
voilà c'est tout je ne suis pas contre
les visites à maison de retraite pas du
tout je suis je suis pour qu'il y ait
une sécurité et je suis pour qu'il y ait
ce contrôle 24 heures avant même s'il y
a un pass vaccinale parce que les gens
maxime et peuvent être contagieux le
sont moins mais ils peuvent l'être
merci nous en étions donc aux 50
rectifié quater qui est un double avis
défavorable qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté le 121 double avis
défavorable qui et pour qui et contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté le
cent soixante dix rectifié biz double
avis défavorable créé pour quelqu'un me
demande de parole monsieur chaize je
n'ai pas vu mes mains présidente je
voudrais donc apporter quelques
compléments aux rapporteurs au justin
explications notamment sur le fait que
si effectivement les photos sont des
données personnelles au regard du rgp
des les solutions qui seraient
envisagées peuvent garantir par une raie
une réalisation sécurisé mais aussi par
le nom stockage
ce qui fait que on aurait pas de
métadonnées et donc pas de problèmes
liés aux aspects des sur la mise en
effectivement j'entends sauf que il faut
bien commencer un jour parce qu'on sera
à chaque fois les éléments et on ne
pourra jamais faire évoluer donc le
système et enfin gère quelque part enfin
pensez aussi à ce que l'on n'en rajoute
pas sur les inconvénients notamment au
niveau des cafetiers ou des
organisateurs et je souhaiterais par cet
amendement faire en sorte qu'on l'ennuie
pas tous ces gens là m'ont dit
coordination c'est celui-là
merci je veux pas d'autre explication de
vote jamais donc on voit le sang sont
directif ye bis avec un double avis
défavorable qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté le groupe d'amendements
identiques
suivant à partir du 80 tombe du fait de
l'adoption du 203 de la commission nous
passons donc aux 173 double avis
défavorable qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adoptée au le 177 double avis
défavorable qui et pour qui et contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adoptée sur
le bloc d'amendements identiques je suis
saisi d'une demande de scrutin public
du groupe socialiste avant que nous
procédions scrutin je vais donner la
parole à et de chez nous
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre nous sommes à une heure avancée
un mois j'ai voté le pass sanitaires et
je vais voter le pass vaccinale mais en
même temps j'ai deux inquiétudes
la question de la sortie et puis la
question du contrôle
alors sur la sortie je pense qu'on aura
d'autres occasions pour en discuter mais
sur cette question du contrôle faut-il
renforcer le contrôle moi
personnellement je vous avoue que je
n'en suis pas sûre faut-il inciter les
bars et restaurants ont leur permettre
de renforcer ce contrôle d'identité
j'ai l'impression d'ailleurs qu' ils ne
sont pas très nombreux à le souhaiter ou
à le demander parce qu'ils sont très
conscients de la difficulté de la mise
en oeuvre et puis surtout il me semble
mais ça a été dit dans la présentation
de ces amendements par mes collègues ça
a été dit par loïc avait par par le
sénateur kahn fait ça a été dit par le
sénateur bonne carrère dans
l'explication de la discussion générale
je pense que nous avons un vrai risque
de basculer dans une autre société
dans le
avec le danger de jeu normes donc je
suis le vertige de la norme le vertige
de contrôle et je pense que même si nous
sommes en pandémie nous devons être
vigilants par rapport à ce vertige qui
existe toujours pour un pouvoir exécutif
et je vais vous dire j'ai un peu plus
loin encore je préfère même que quelques
personnes puissent se glisser avec des
passes
sanitaires ou dépassent ou impasse
vaccinale un certain que de prendre le
risque de basculer dans une société
qu'on a du mal à imaginer qui m'apparaît
dangereuse voilà la raison pour laquelle
je voterai ces amendements jour merci
y at il d'autres explications de vote
avant que nous procédions au scrutin
public
donc je vous rappelle que sur ces
amendements dont je vous redonne les
numéros 7 rectifié bis 17 19 51 58 71 85
464 et 168 l'avis de la commission est
un avis de sagesse et l'avis du
gouvernement un avis défavorable
il va être procédé au scrutin
j'ai pu lui si l'on tousse auto vide
c'est bon
le scrutin est ouvert ce autant 343
exprimé 340 pour 303 contre 37 le sénat
a donc adopté l'adoption de ces
amendements fait tomber les deux
amendements suivante que nous n'avons
donc pas de raison de soumettre au vote
[Musique]